pas encore égoutter
pour
santé
m
devant plus de 4000 personnes isabelle
aubret chante jean ferrat sans ciller
alors qu'elle vient d'apprendre le matin
même la mort de l'artiste c'est en 1962
qu'il fait sa connaissance d'un
véritable coup de foudre amical et c'est
elle qui va chanter ferrat dans le monde
entier c'est plus qu'un ami qu'opère et
n'y a pas que nous je pense que le
public le public perd quelque chose de
précieux quelqu'un qui servirent les
choses qu'ils savaient déchanter idées
d'hier les les écrire et même si depuis
ce fonds de 13 il s'était arrêté de
chanter je suis
je suis sa messagère je l'emmène partout
les années d'isabelle aubret sont là
pour la soutenir et puis il ya également
gérard meyes son producteur depuis 1959
il rappelle l'intégrité de l'artiste son
engagement son humour aussi et sa grande
exigence sierra savez très bien que vous
voulez pas de lui puisqu'il m'a toujours
dit tu vas devenir mon imprésario par
exemple et je lui dis mais je ne sais
même pas ce que ça imprésario il m'a
toujours dit tu sais c'est très simple
c'est quelqu'un qui a un téléphone tout
en un et un calendrier jetant nos freins
et je suis devenu l'imprésario comme ça
et une autre carrière s'est fait
ensemble en fait et dans la plus pure
indépendance je crois que nous sommes
les seuls indépendante
1972 jean ferrat savait manier les mots
avec la musique qu'il est mort en
ardèche cette région qui lui a inspiré
la chanson la montagne qui demeure l'une
de ses plus célèbres compositions
comment
le